i'm jp sears i'm the ceo of cancel
culture and today because of his new
special we're officially canceling dave
chappelle every year or two when
chappelle releases a new special we go
into right alert it's like the olympics
for us at kinsler culture it's what
we've been training all year for
we've never been successful at canceling
him in the past
but that's not going to stop us from
trying this time special seems like the
outrage continues it seems like
i don't want to speak too soon but it
seems like
this might be the tipping point yes it
seems like the executives might have
realized that they could push back
and there will be more support in their
pushback than there will be in their
cancellation and i think
i think chappelle
is an example of someone who's
too big to fail right in other words
like at the end of the day like these
people are capitalists right they're not
moralists they're capitalists right so
as they should be they exist in a
capitalist country and uh when we're
talking about like saying words and
saying jokes
you're not listen i'm not gonna define
like how you're actually hurting
somebody but you're not basically saying
you you're not equal to other people
right right
being spoken about is different than
treating someone actually differently in
terms of like the law like if if the
head of netflix came out and said like
yeah we just don't do any trans shows on
this platform that would be wrong right
but if the head of netflix is like hey
we have jokes about black people we have
jokes about jews we have jokes about
puerto ricans we have jokes about asians
everybody gets joked about on this
platform including trans there is more
consistency even if you're outraged all
of those groups can also be outrageous
right but he is big enough yeah where
it's worth the scrutiny yes and
maybe that's unfortunate for like a
younger comic coming up but the same
time you get to look at you go oh [ __ ]
there's a tipping point yeah i can get
successful enough to say what the [ __ ] i
had a lot of our most elite cancel
culture revolutionaries have taken not
just to their blogs that have a
readership of dozens of people but
they're also hitting the comment section
in social media hard right now since he
released his special we're in an all-out
war with dave chappelle's comedy and
we're pointing out obvious things like
he has bad joke structure his jokes are
predictable and his comedy is nothing
but lazy and for his sake i personally
hope dave listens to all of our
non-comedian activists critique of his
comedy
so one day maybe the greatest comedian
of all time will become a good comedian
when sticks and stones came out a lot of
people in the trans community were
furious with me and the hardest thing
for a person to do is go against their
tribe but definitely did that for me and
when she did that the trans community
dragged that [ __ ] all over twitter but
six days after that wonderful night i
described to you my friend daphne
killed herself
i don't know if it was them dragon i
don't know what's going on in her life
but i bet dragging her didn't help
this is a good conversation what you
mean it sparks a really good
conversation because you know you can't
tell people how to react and you can't
tell people you know what should and
shouldn't offend them but i wonder if
the folks who are outraged know
that their intentions are actually
malicious dave chappelles are not so
dave says something his intention is to
be funny you reply today but your
intention is actually to be hurtful
because you feel dave hurt you but what
if that hurt you were projecting that
you took out on dave and daphne
contributed to her taking her life now
daphne's sisters have since defended
dave chappelle they said dave loved my
sister and is lgbtq ally his entire set
was begging to end this very situation
and
what he's saying to the lgbtq family is
i see you do you see me i'm mourning my
friend in the best way i know how can
you see me can you allow me that and she
called the set a call to come together
and according to uh
you know other messages becky who is
daphne's sister also said she did not
find his jokes crude off coloring off
putting anything she thought his jokes
were funny
and daphne understood humor and comedy
she was not offended why would her
family be offended so that is the family
speaking out the idea that chappelle
actually loves and honors people in the
trans community and is simply using this
comedy to point out a few areas where
objective reality has been lost sight of
is something our chief nuance officer is
taking a look at
looks like that's not what he's doing
according to us some people believe it
though and think chappelle is dedicated
to serving humanity by helping them
connect to truth in areas where they
need it but someone who didn't like the
soulless lack of truth in hollywood so
much so that he walked away from a 50
million dollar contract because truth
and authenticity matter more to him
probably wouldn't do something like that
believe it or not there are some people
out there who just want to break all the
beautiful things in the world and these
people want netflix right bloody now to
cancel dave chappelle remove the special
they want him to apologize and disappear
from the world critics are filthy news
publications are screaming from the
rooftops people all over the internet
cannot believe that a giant streaming
platform like netflix would allow
another straight white commit
dave's black
dave is black so that means he must have
done something real bloody bad you may
be thinking well if the twitter people
and the internet folk are going after
dave chappelle a person of color he must
have done something unconscionable
unbelievable and terrible like
sacrificing a child live on stage a
disabled child at that but no no no it's
worse netflix is facing calls to drop
the comedian special the closer after
his latest comments about transgender
people oh it's people are mad this comes
from npr in his new netflix special dave
chappelle tries and often fails to
justify button pushing jokes about gay
people trans people and feminists
rights critic eric diggins hey eric
diggins [ __ ] you to the moon
special we found it very inappropriate
that dave chappelle used his comedy
performance to speak his mind instead of
our mind and therefore we found it very
hateful here at cancel culture we know
the facts and the facts are dave
chappelle is not funny
men can give birth water is dry and fire
is wet
let's not be stupid here this is what
we're talking about when we talk about
when people mention cancer culture
you'll have some people and i used to
get bothered with bill bursting you know
there's like right there's like two guys
in the audience they get over it right
it's not about two guys in the audience
it's about some people in a position of
power who really don't deserve to be in
that position of power amplifying their
voice to try and take away your
livelihood it's about comedians going
and complaining to the booker so you
never get stage time we're no one is
arguing that these people are the
majority no one is arguing that by the
way a white straight male who produces a
show from the black american point of
view titled dear white people who only
transitioned more at december 2020 went
from this
to this
right so it's a straight white male
canceling a black man no one is arguing
that that is the majority unfortunately
they are in positions of power to
dictate what you the majority get to
watch so when people say it's not a
thing it's accountability culture no
it's not
it's not it's people who get furious at
somebody for making a joke about
biological sex and then go to the most
powerful network in the world where they
happen to be a showrunner for i don't
know if it's popular but certainly one
of their uh hallmark shows dear white
people saying i am going to i'm not
going to do any work for you until you
fire this guy
for having a different point of view can
anyone imagine it going the other way
like you know what netflix if dave
chappelle said i'm not going to finish
my contract with you until you take away
the pro-transgender agenda pieces that
you push on kids i'm not going to give
you anything on netflix until you take
away girls
twerking and booty shorts how about that
no you can never imagine this going the
other way it's also the perfect group to
pick to be canceled for
because the majority of people truly
don't understand trans
so
people do understand gay even if they
don't like it they understand it right
they empathize with it they have an
uncle that's gay they have a cousin
that's gay they have a friend it's gay
there's something about homosexuality
that's just way more understandable
they've seen characters in their
favorite tv shows that are gay they
understand it you probably have a gay
family member yeah that's what i was
saying i don't know yeah
yeah um so so there it's just way more
digestible homosexuality so when you're
saying something that the gay community
is offering pushback for
all of a sudden you start thinking about
that human being that you know you love
right
trans is so foreign to the average
person right like i know mark you said
you have a trans friend but like anybody
else here have not only transferred like
a trans person in any way in their life
yep
who
mark's friend that he just said that he
knows anyway
well anyway
someone
literally the person that serves you
coffee at your favorite diner yeah no
not at all it is such a small part of
the population that occupies such a
large part of the conversation right
because i'm sure it's thrown into this
culture war a little bit but it's the
perfect group that if you have to get
cancelled for something because the
majority of people we're not talking
about industry the majority of people
have no [ __ ] clue what the trans
thing is so they're kind of like i don't
really care what you say it's like
getting canceled for like the hmong
chinese population it's like how many is
that exactly so so now if you're a
network executive like hold on i'm gonna
cancel the biggest comedian
for a group of people that don't even
got a netflix account like yeah
yeah i mean like i don't
0.1 of netflix accounts are from this
community i'm gonna cancel my biggest
comic for that yeah i'm a capitalist
right and that don't make no [ __ ]
sense